Here our solution is plus or minus three i an imaginary solution, pretty cool.
We take the square root of both sides to get x is equal to plus or minus the
square root of negative nine. Now we've simplified this radical and remember
that negative square roots, need to be simplified using i. We can break this
radical down into the square root of 9 times the square root of negative 1.
Then we replace the square root of negative 1 with i. We can also check our
result. We know the answers are not 3 and negative 3. Since 3 squared would
equal positive 9 not negative 9. Also at negative 3 squared would be positive
9. Not negative nine like we want in our equation. So since these answers are
out, let's make sure the plus or minus 3i works in our equation. I'm going to
check our positive 3i here in this equation and our negative 3i here in this
equation. When we square the quantity of 3i, we get 3 squared which is 9 and i
squared. When we square negative 3i negative 3 times negative 3 is positive 9,
and i squared is i squared. And remember back from before, i squared equals
negative 1. So we can substitute that in here. This effectively changes the
sign of these terms. This gives us a check of negative 9 equal to negative 9 in
both cases. So we could be confident knowing that our answers are correct.